hello everyone and welcome to yet
another game from the st. Louis rabid in
blitz tournament I know I said I wasn't
gonna show anymore but this one really
deserves showing and it does come as a
suggestion from a subscriber so here it
is a suggestion from mr. haire Abdullah
Yusuf he says that I know this is the
last game you will review from the boots
and Rapids but I'll be happy if hash tag
suggestion you can review the Fabiana
Carano vs. ding Liron game in the last
round beautiful miniature by i whited
out the name here so it doesn't ruin it
for you tactical fireworks and this is
why the hashtag suggestion is so
important
without mr. use of suggesting it I would
not have even seen the game and it's
really a beauty so before we check out
the game we do have to choose the
thumbnail so there it is the coin toss
all right
I'm just gonna check it out that it is
very interesting now let's check out the
game so Cora wanna with the white pieces
is the final round he opens with E 4 we
have c6 adding goes for the caro-kann
defense with d4 d5
story about that and here it captures on
d5 the exchange variation will see
captures on d5 and now Bishop to d3 we
have Knight to c6 c3 now strengthen in
the center and now Queen to c7 with h3
and here Knight to f6 the exchange
variation isn't all that popular and
classical chest our but for blitz it can
always use abused as a surprise for
example Anand plated against the onion
punishing the grand chester paris that
we've covered recently only nipple
played play tonight we're sorry never
played g6 here but the dink continues
with Knight to f6 which is the main move
in this line with Knight the a3 by Fabi
and now a6 taking away the be 5 square
from whites night and night back the c2
and now g6 we have 9th to 3 and Bishop
to f5 offering a trade of Bishops where
white can play Bishop captures for
example Bishop captures here and the
double of blacks pawns but as White will
most likely Castle kingside you don't
want to give the semi open G file to
blacks rook so with Bishop back to e to
Bobby it declines the trade and now come
now comes a sex which is a new move into
position there is one game in the
database for Bishop to g7 was played by
the Dean now plays a six and we have a
completely new game already unmoved in
fabric castles King side and here with
h5 and already you can see that thing is
trying to push on the King side to
create some sort of an attack and it's
still unclear where dings King is going
to go maybe Queen side or King side
that's kind of has a nice ring to it
dings King but okay Fabi continues
Knight Sita you want preparing to remain
over the knight to d3 we have Bishop to
d6 and now knife to d3 and here again
ding leaves the options open whether to
cast King set or Queen side but as the
pawns on the King said I'll are already
quite advanced it's most likely that he
will Castle queenside we have Knight to
e4 an excellent outpost for four dings
night Bobby would also enjoy such an
outpost on on e5 but the Dean has a firm
grasp on d5 square and also you can
always kick away the night with f6 with
Bishop to e3 by fabi
and now with castles Queen side biding
and now far we would very much enjoy
starting an attack for example something
like a4 b4 b5 but you can't push b4
since the c3 Knight would be hanging so
first Fabi goes rook to c1 and here Bing
doesn't allow Fabi to start pushing he
plays g5 already starts the attack even
though it comes as a as basically just a
pawn sacrifice here ding offers the g5
pawn now how do you defend you can
either ignore it you can start an attack
or of your own or you can play with Fabi
play tonight capture some g5 you just
grab the pawn and next move you're gonna
strengthen the night with either h4 or
f4 with rook D to G 8 now then plays
rook v2j it you don't want to play it on
the previous move and allow Fabi to
start pushing he first sacrificed upon
and only then much like makalah would do
you know just to make the attack happen
a little bit sooner and here
h4 is the move fob you should have
played but he tried a different line he
played f4 it also strengthens the night
but it allows a tactic that well
fortunately for Fabi being overlooked
but you are welcome to
the video here and to try and find this
idea that both of them missed while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent you
know
spotter of ideas that were missed by
both players and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
rook captures on g5 it just creates a
wonderful idea as there are so many dark
square weaknesses around the white king
now of course white would have to
capture and then worship H to check the
F 2 square is covered by the night King
H 1 only move and now Knight G 3 check
Bishop covers G 1 King captures and H 2
is only moved Knight captures an f1 a
double check from the Queen and the
night now if King H 1 then Queen H 2 is
made so you have to play King g2 now
just capture an e3 with an attack on the
Queen and well White's position isn't
all that great and also black is up a
full piece so black is completely
winning here now the reason why I didn't
miss this is because he found another
interesting line Knight to g3 first and
okay now Fabi has to react to his rook
being attacked rook to f2 now defending
and now comes f6
kicking the knight back Knight to f3 and
now the move ding so probably why he
decided not to look any further and he
missed the bishop root cap force and g5
Knight to e4 and here
Fabi has to decide does he want to lose
the exchange or does he want to allow
the attack with Bishop captures on h3 as
the G pawn is pinned to do to the rook
on g8 Bobby decides it's better to you
know save the exchange so look to f1 and
I'll dink captures Bishop captures on h3
we have night after he won now defending
and here we have h4 h4 is a is what I
think would best be described as a blitz
move the reason
pretty much everyone can see that Bishop
captures on g2 probably goes but in in
blitz you may be you're alone the clock
you want to play h4 and then after you
capture on g2 you know you can always
push h3 and win your piece back but this
was a classical game we would probably
see something like Bishop captures and
g2 I'm just gonna show it as it's really
a beautiful line Knight captures and now
Queen g7 threatening mate and after y
defends this with something like
look f 2 or even Bishop to f3 now you
push h4 you threaten h3 and after king
h2 trying to unpin now h3 and after
nights GE 1 now you play Queen g3 check
King each one and now Queen g2 check a
beautiful Queen sacrifice after Bishop
captures you capture with the with the
pawn H captures and G 2 kings you want
and now rook each one is mate as the
night covers the f2 square this is
probably what we would see if this was a
classical game but age for being prefers
a safe move he knows he can capture on
g2 and always push h3 on the next move
so with King 2h 2 again Fabi tries to
run pin and now Queen to g7 again
threatening Queen g3 check with Bishop
to f3 putting the yet another defender
to the g2 pawn also Bishop captures and
g2 was a threat but now Dean plays it
with bishop characters and g2 Bishop
captures and g2 and now Queen to g3
check King to h1 and now comes Queen
captures and III just grabbing a piece
there and here we have Roop to f3 by
Fabi so here once again feel free to
pause the video and try to find a
winning idea for for being in this
position it's actually a force mating 4
so let's just see how you do so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
creator of miniatures with the black
pieces and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show here h3 wins the
game this is what being played and this
is where fabulous on the game as there
is nothing more to do here the obvious
replies that rook captures Queen but
then we get a similar mate H captures
Angie to check King's you wanna only
move and now rook each one is mate
because the night covers the f2 square
and if you try something else after h3
not capturing the Queen but what else is
there you could try Bishop f1 but then
just Queen g3 the two queens you want is
mate as the rook defends the Queen so
after rook to f3 now father resigned the
game and a beautiful miniature for ding
Liron really thank you for hash tag
suggesting that as I would most likely
miss this game there are so many blitz
games play played it's impossible to
check all of them and that's why I
always you know say state
how important it is for you to suggest
games because even though I follow
pretty much everything what goes on in
the chess world it's impossible to find
all the nice games but yeah for those of
you who might have missed it in the
previous round here are the standings
after at the end of the st. Louis rapid
in blitz and also sorry about that I
forgot to mention in the previous video
I said that all of all the people who
were trying to catch up to Levin have
won their games in the last round that's
not true
you young he drew his game and that's
the reason why he didn't catch up to 11
because 11 lost the game in last round
against Maxie Marshall de Graaff we saw
which we saw that in the previous video
but there we have it 11 one event with
22 points then followed by three people
with 21 and a half ding maxime beaugeois
Grove in new youngji 19 and a half
second Magnus crossing with 17 richard
rapport with 16 and a half then Fabiano
Caruana with 15 Domingues paris with 13
and a half and the sharma media of last
with 12 points so there we have it that
was the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and also a special announcement
well not regarding me but the world
official random Championship is coming
up and I've just learned today that
Fabiana Khurana will play a 20 game
match against Garry Kasparov so that's
gonna be really awesome I'm very much
looking forward to that and we're gonna
check some games from that as I don't
think I've ever covered a official
random game maybe I think I covered one
the were very shook check me that call
sent in seven moves but I think that's
the only one Maria that's it for this
video I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Pavel Atanas of trading
stick run item and motley Bogdanski for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
Capablanca saga checking up on your
suggestions nice ones such as this one
and of course checking up on everything
that goes on in the chess world thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend